it's 2021 and the fbi is investigating
widespread match fixing allegations in
counter-strike
and we're not talking about random
players throwing meaningless matches for
a few hundred bucks
no we're potentially talking about
organized syndicates
paying players to throw professional
matches
now not all of the details have been
made public yet
but if the initial reports are true this
controversy could shake counter-strike
and ballarat to its very core
okay hit the sub button like the video
hit that notification bell so you never
miss new content and
if you want to see a story covered here
on don't at me send us a tip at tips at
thescore.com
last week we learned that the fbi is
working in collaboration with the
esports integrity commission or
esic to investigate match fixing in n a
counter strike on march 31st the head of
esic
ian smith did an interview with a small
youtuber by the name of slash 32
and said exactly that to some extent
working with law enforcement with the
fbi who
only recently have had a sports betting
investigative unit within the fbi so
they're quite
um they're good but they're
inexperienced
because sports betting has never been a
big thing in america until recently
and so everybody's kind of finding their
feet on that one
now smith referred to this situation as
a classic case of match fixing
meaning quote outside betting syndicates
were bribing players to throw
matches and apparently this wasn't just
random players doing it sporadically
and the amount that's being thrown
around right now is two thousand dollars
per player per
match fix it's essentially the type of
match fixing more commonly seen in
professional sports
here's flom and slasher talking about
that during an entire stream
dedicated to the controversy two
thousand dollars per player guys
was the average that richard was saying
yesterday that these guys were thrown
for matches
two thousand dollars to compromise you
have
so little confidence in your own ability
to be successful in counter-strike
that you threw a [ __ ] match for two
thousand dollars
according to smith this situation is
systemic within
nacs go it involves a small specific
group of players
it's been happening for quite a long
time and apparently
they have a ton of evidence things like
discord messages
betting slips other chat logs in order
to prove it
smith concluded that portion of the
interview by saying that e6 should be
able to release a statement within the
next two weeks
now not surprisingly the cs go scene
lost its collective [ __ ]
speculating on who could be involved
what kind of evidence they could have
and how
serious these allegations are that
speculation was fueled by videos like
this one that slash 32 posted
which speculates that former mdl players
and now prominent professional valorant
players
poised shanks and marv were all involved
today we're going to cover a cs go game
in esea premiere of the mountain dew
league that was suspected to be thrown
by shanks poised and marved whom
are all successful valorent players i
put this first clip in just because i
thought this was a very
questionable push especially on the
first gun round and
and really clips like this kind of
they're very subjective and you can kind
of think what you want but
they they litter the whole demo then on
april 1st
dexerados richard lewis reported that
valerant developer riot games
launched its own investigation into
former mdl players suspected of match
fixing who had switched over to ballarat
with poised shanks and marved all being
included in that list
now recently after a short trial run
dignitas decided not to sign shanks to
its valorant team
and they dropped poised from its roster
entirely
marved on the other hand is currently
the igl for faze clan's valorent roster
here's phlom on players potentially
breaking the law and how switching to
valerian isn't some magical solution
because
as we know riot games can jump in and
investigate that [ __ ] too
it felt like i was in a simulation where
like everybody else is just like
oh they're not even gonna get banned and
violent like mother they broke the law
people are like so disconnected from
reality now
on the internet it's terrifying these
dudes are literally saying because
they're playing a different video game
they don't deserve punishment
when they broke the [ __ ] law then on
april 2nd
hltv subsidiary dust 2 reported a leaked
conversation between
mdl players rechi 4 pack and nosrak
discussing plans to fix two different
matches
the recording was sent in anonymously
but according to dust2 they've been able
to verify the players involved
by speaking with other esea premier
division players
now in the written transcript of the
audio which we're showing you
here wretched and four pack from team
rebirth are allegedly discussing an
upcoming match against a team called
russian canadians that they were
planning to throw
they talk about the fact that russian
canadians as igl
vek allegedly agreed to radar for them
and i'll explain what that means in just
a second but
first here's a quote from the transcript
quote
he does he agrees to radar on the
condition that i'm letting him
use two bitcoin sites and i'm going to
share profit from those two sites
and joel's is okay with it too and
they're not
i told them there's no way you tell
battery or saturn
it needs to look like a legit try-hard
game
end quote so two things getting someone
to radar for you
is when someone streams their radar and
discord to the opposing team
allowing that opposing team to play off
any information
given and the whole point of getting
someone to radar for you is to make the
loss look as
authentic as possible basically
it's a good way not to get caught match
fixing
the second thing pertains to that last
line of the quote that i read you
quote i told them there's no way you
tell
battery or saturn it needs to look like
a legit
try-hard game end quote so these dudes
allegedly weren't even going to tell
their teammates what they planned on
doing
as a result of dust 2's report and the
leaked audio
on april 3rd esea who runs
mdl announced that three players from
team rebirth and two players from
russian canadians
would be suspended until the conclusion
of esic's investigation
they ended the tweet by saying quote we
continue to support
esic and will always enforce actions
against violations of competitive
integrity
endcorp now stick with me for just a
second back in february before any of
this was reported
vec who you'll remember as russian
canadians igl
somehow learned about this recording and
released a twitlonger disavowing
anything to do with match fixing quote
it has come to my attention that a
report regarding na match fixing will be
released
soon in this report allegedly there will
be evidence of someone saying my name
regarding a match
i would like to clarify that the alleged
fixed
match was not played it was a forfeit
loss
also there is no evidence of me
personally agreeing to
anything because i am not involved at
all
this person says my name i do not know
why
i cannot control whose name they say and
for what reason
i am preemptively making this statement
because i cannot foresee how this
evidence
will be presented by whomever is going
to release it
if any platform decides to ban me on
conjecture alone
then my hope is people recognize that
and be aware of it moving forward
end quote and like i said this is all
anyone paying attention to
counter-strike and valerian is
talking about and rightfully so here's
another clip from flom and slasher
discussing the controversy on stream
i don't want to say they should go to
prison but i also do because
it's not like we said this is far worse
than the bipartisan area where we're
dealing with people that intentionally
manipulated a system for their own gain
and worked with others to do it like
this is straight up just like organized
crime this isn't like kids
you know making a mistake like it is but
it also isn't right like it's a bit more
than that
like flom mentioned in that clip this
controversy
could blow the i buy power scandal from
2015
right out of the [ __ ] water like with
the fbi involved who
knows how big this can be once all the
details are released
and if you don't know what the hell
happened with eyebuy power well
we've covered that story roughly a
million times
csgo's 2015 matrix and scandal is one of
the biggest scandals in the game's
history
four of north america's strongest
players were banned overnight
cutting their pro career short okay with
the most recent
news out of the way how the f did we get
to this point
this situation is so serious the fbi
felt the need to
step in well see esik has investigated
a ton of different counter-strike
scandals over the last
year or so it roughly started in august
of 2020 when tournament organizer esl
announced that certain cs go coaches
were abusing a known spectator bug
then in september isik came out with a
ruling
banning coaches who abused that bug and
at that point in time personalities in
the scene were chomping at the bit for
more
info flam for example tweeted out that
he had heard rumors
but wanted to see concrete proof of
match fixing in mdl
after retired cs gopro and current
valorem pros
celsius vaguely accused a bunch of
players on stream
esports
[Music]
they had
see people could tell something big was
coming down the pipe but at
this point in time the fbi were still
just a skin you could buy and
counter-strike
nobody thought that a government agency
was going to get involved
then in december of 2020 esic dropped a
giant report claiming that there were
widespread instances of stream sniping
happening at the highest levels of cs go
and then
in january of this year they dropped
what was a bombshell report at the time
stating that 35 australian cs go players
were banned
due to instances of illicit betting we
also covered that situation when it
happened
35 counter-strike players have been
banned from one
to five years after an investigation
into illicit
betting all according to a report from
the esports integrity commission
and the crazy part is this might just be
the beginning
now in the statement esik released
regarding the australian betting bans
they wrote
this quote esic is currently undertaking
other investigations which compromise
the examination
of a number of other cs go leagues
including leagues located in north
america
europe in a significant number of other
leagues and multiple game
titles and this is the first official
hint that we got that esic was looking
into something
bigger other than just random players
betting on matches
i reached out to smith for comment
regarding the fbi's involvement in this
investigation but didn't hear back in
time for publication
now obviously this situation is insane
and we
all have a million questions here's
where i'm at with all of this
this situation could end careers and
affect the future of counter-strike
sure but more importantly this could
have a huge
effect on valoran's young competitive
scene
think about it depending on the names
involved and the scope of riot's own
investigation
how many tier one names could be
implicated in this scandal
slasher tweeted as much recently so the
question becomes
if riot does find specific players
guilty of egregiously match fixing
what do they do in my mind it doesn't
matter that it happened in a different
game
if you let the results of an fbi
investigation go
unpunished you have a huge pr
disaster on your hands i can't believe i
have to say this but if you match fixed
in one
game switching esports does not
magically stop the fbi from coming after
you
this is a criminal investigation we're
talking about here like imagine we
learned that big splashy orgs propping
up the tier 1 scene
unknowingly signed someone who match
fixed in another
game do they immediately kick that
player or
just let it ride also i know valve is
notoriously hands-off when it comes to
cs go's competitive scene
but they have commented on previous
e-cic investigations
so i'm curious to see how they'll
respond to this one for the moment
though
all we can do is wait and see how bad
the damage
actually is
come on down to f1 devin's auto body
where i will not
sell you a car and i'll just tell you
everything's off the only dealer that
tells you down
hurry up [ __ ] this event ends the
minute after you write us a check and it
better not bouncer you're a dead
[ __ ] go to hell
you in the [ __ ] face